public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles cette
semaine l'enquète de cette émission nous
emmène en irlande c'est l'un des deux
états européens où l'avortement est
interdit
mais le débat est relancé dans le pays
mais tout de suite le cas de chypre qui
continuent à secouer toute l'europe avec
nos invités nous verrons si nous pouvons
laisser notre argent dans les banques
européennes
c'est l'histoire d'un petit territoire
deux bouts d'europe menacés par la
faillitte qui connaît chypre si ce n'est
pour ses plages et ses banques
il faut dire que le secteur bancaire
chypriote représente 900 % de son pib
alors on parle du père trophy bancaire
hypertrophie une jolie feinte pour ne
pas dire paradis fiscal comment un
paradis fiscal en plein coeur de la zone
euro vous plaisantez
pas vraiment alors que faire pour sauver
chypre une fois de plus fmi bce
eurogroupe ont inventé un dispositif
dont eux seuls ont le secret taxer les
dépôts bancaires
cafouillage ultimatum règlements de
compte et réunion de la dernière chance
le sauvetage dans l'urgence à une
nouvelle fois fait vaciller la zone euro
et pendant ce temps à nicosie en
attendant la sortie de crise
on sent comme un air de déjà vu dans les
rues chypriote
les manifestations se suivent et se
ressemblent banque clause économie en
panne entreprises fermées magasins
dévalisés
un air de graisse 1er d'espagne
un air de portugal alors
à tout sacrifier chypre alors notre
invité aujourd'hui et jean paul gauzès
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen français vous êtes membre du
ppe est également membre de la
commission des affaires économiques et
monétaires ici au parlement européen
est-ce que lorsque le roux groupe a
décidé de prendre de l'argent sur les
comptes des chypriotes quel qu'il soit
est ce que l'eurogroupe n'a pas commis
là une erreur point que la grossière
erreur a été la façon dont les choses
ont été semble-t-il réfléchie est
annoncé sur le problème de fond on peut
on peut poser en se poser des questions
mais il est clair qu'il était vraiment
détestable de laisser entendre que
c'était l'europe qui prélevés sur les
ponts des particuliers alors qu'en
réalité c'est une proposition qui est
faite à l'état chypriote et le parlement
chypriote avait le dernier mot et on l'a
bien vu il a refusé pendant que
j'aimerais comprendre en fait ce que
vous dites c'est que c'était acceptable
de prendre de l'argent sur des comptes
ont trouvé leur on pouvait se trouver
oui parce que fait il ya deux choses il
faut pas confondre il ya la fortune
personnelle des gens les par unité
déposés et puis les dépôts au sens
bancaire les limitations dont tout le
monde parle cent mille euros c'est une
limitation
c'est une protection c'est une garantie
dans le cas où la banque qui reçoit les
dépôts fait faillite
là nous n'étions pas dans un cas de
faillite de la banque avérée dans la
faim dans le schéma qui était prévu l on
réfléchisse a évolué mais dans le schéma
qui était prévu à réty s'agissait d'un
impôt sur la fortune
prélever directement à la source mais
comme ça a été très mal présentés
évidemment chacun à penser qu'elle
s'était d'autres choses quelle que soit
la présentation qu'on fait de toute
façon à la fin
il ya eu des personnes qui rue de
l'argent directement retirer de leurs
contres donc tout ce que vous dites
c'est que c'est pas un problème de
décision la décision était bonne mais
elle a été mal présentée dans le choix
de la décision il fallait s'intéresser
sur l'interrogeait sur les conséquences
mais ce qu'est ce qui a commencé mais la
confusion et malheureusement je crains
durablement
c'est la mauvaise présentation d'abord
parce que c'est pas leur groupe qui
décidé de ponctionner l'eurogroupe
disait nous prêterons 10 milliards si
vous vous en trouvez 6 ou 5,8 et il
demandait aux chiffres aux chypriotes
comment vous allez trouver ses 5,8
une des réponses a été j'étais pas la
réunion ne s'est pas le français s'est
passé ça a été que tous se sont mis
d'accord y compris le chypriote pour le
fait qu'il y ait une taxe dans ses
derniers mots qu'ils soient prélevés sur
l'épargné des gens qui avaient déposé en
banque ça veut dire même pas des
chiffriers de tous ceux qui avaient
déposé y compris et on sait pourquoi des
déposants étrangers qui ont en fait la
plus grande masse et pour des coûts en
chypre est notée chez les russes mais
aussi des britanniques vous par les
problèmes de communication l'eurogroupe
qui a pris à l'unanimité cette décision
est dirigé par un nouveau président à c
y et ronon dex omhm un hollandais un
néerlandais
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils impriment
de compétence de cet homme dans la
gestion de la crise compétences en sais
rien je les ai rencontrés récemment je
pense qu'il est compétent mais il est
très nouveau dans la fonction il
tomberait la fonction de ministre des
finances
et je pense honnêtement mais peut-être
parce que j'aime bien jean claude
juncker que l'expérience de jean claude
juncker au recteur et ses soeurs étaient
son prédécesseur aurait certainement
amener un peu plus de bon sens dans la
façon de gérer ce dossier même si c'est
un dossier difficile et si chypre il
faut quand même le dire à nos ados à nos
auditeurs c'est que chypre n'est pas un
pays comme les autres dans la zone euro
deux pays très particulier et si je
voulais être un peu méchant pour les
chypriotes je dirais que c'est une
grosse lessiveuse pour blanchiment est
un lieu de parler fiscal comme le disait
votre reportage est ce qu'aujourd'hui
quand même à là il n'y a pas une pour un
problème de confiance dans la zone euro
est ce que les les déposants partout
ailleurs dans la zone euro que ce soit
par progress en espagne en italie
pourquoi pas même en france est ce que
aujourd'hui
peuvent ne pas avoir des doutes
raisonnablement sur le fait qu'ils vont
pouvoir conserver leur je pense que les
déposants ont effectivement des doutes
on à leur encontre
il n'ya pas dire que les déposants qui
ont des doutes et aussi des doutes au
niveau international sur le comportement
de la gouvernance de la zone euro qui
peut donner l'impression d'être très
chaotique c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
alors est-ce qu'ils ont raison d'avoir
créé des craintes
je pense que aujourd'hui la situation
chypriote alors je sais bien a dit pour
la grèce se reproduira pas mais les
chiffres c'était prévisible et je crois
que ce qui est condamnable c'est que
notamment la commission n'ait pas été
plus vigilante
depuis plusieurs années sur ce qui se
passait à chypre je pense la situation
de chypre est unique en europe et donc
et sa vue sur la grèce oui mais elle
était unique là elle est une autre c'est
une autre unicité parce que c'est pas le
même problème
la grèce est un problème
d'appauvrissement totale du pays et de
difficultés graves durable et qui
tiennent à situation économique de la
grèce là pour chypre c'est le fait d'une
surdimensionnement de la borne qui fait
courir les risques parce que les banques
ne sont plus à la hauteur des risques
qu'ils prennent non pas les liquidités
nécessaires mais je crois que nos
concitoyens peuvent avoir des doutes
chacun peut avoir des doutes je crois
que raisonnablement d'un étang
prévisible le risque de mise en cause
des dépôts est très faible est en tout
cas les procédures qui sont actuellement
à l'étude pour l'avenir doivent
permettre de garantir que ça ne puisse
pas se passer de cette manière risque
d'être faible
mais il existe encore un mois jamais
exclure de moi je sais que mon argent ou
le houleux où le vôtre qui sur sur des
comptes en banque et passe sous nos
matelas il peut à un moment être prêt
oui dans l'hypothèse où on est en train
de mettre en place des principes de
résolution des crises bancaires pour
éviter qu'elles n'atteignent ces dégâts
et donc l'objectif de ces mesures qui
sont prises au niveau européen et est
évidemment de permettre qu'il n'y ait
pas faire en sorte qu'ils aient pas de
crise bancaire mais l'autre aspect c'est
s'il y avait une crise bancaire
on veut préserver les contribuables
c'est une volonté politique est donc
entre la banque et des contribuables
entre temps il ya des actionnaires de la
banque qui doivent être en première
ligne en cas de responsabilité
financière
et puis il y a éventuellement les
déposant au travers de deux clauses
qu'on appelle les b line c'est à dire
des possibilités de ne rembourser qu'une
partie des sommes qui sont là si la
banque est en grande difficulté mais je
crois que cette situation peut être
exclue aujourd'hui dans des pays comme
la france les pays bas
même l'italie et spy regarder le
redressement les mesures de redressement
n'est ce pas ils sont pressés sans mise
en cause des dépôts des épargnants
jean paul gauzès dernière question sur
l'avenir chypre aujourd'hui il va être
renflouée l'europe va lui prêter dix
milliards d'euros
est ce que dans deux mois on va pas se
retrouver tous les deux l'un en face de
l'autre en train de parler de nouveau de
chypre parce que de toute façon chypre
ne pourra pas rembourser
je crois que
on l'a vu pour la grèce bien souvent on
fait des calendriers les gens qui
réfléchissent peut-être passé font des
calendriers qui sont pas cohérents avec
la réalité pour lâcher pour la grèce
j'étais de ceux qui pensaient qu'il
fallait faire une restructuration
immédiate à l'époque on disait qu'on
était foutu ça ne serait jamais s est
faite elle s'est faite plus tard ça
coûtait plus cher pour chypre on a tardé
là on prend des mesures fortes mais
effectivement le risque existe que par
les faits les conséquences économiques
sur sur chypre et notamment par une
disparition de l'activité bancaire ou de
certaines activités bancaires la
situation de chypre surply tommy
deviennent plus mauvaise merci beaucoup
jean paul gauzès d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
on va rester sur chypre parce
qu'évidemment les télévisions
européennes en ont beaucoup parlé nous
allons recevoir
christian spillmann qui est journaliste
de l'afp est ici à bruxelles
mais tout d'abord je vous propose de
regarder ce zapping des télévisions
européennes
il est signé aurait dit à face chypre
des paillis et appelle à l'aide le
président chypriote et les bailleurs de
fonds entame alors des tractations qui
aboutissent dans 12 une journée marathon
de négociations a permis de boucler
l'accord de sauvetage par lequel chypre
va commencer à recevoir son aide de 10
milliards d'euros à partir du mois de
mai en contrepartie notamment de la
liquidation de la banque
l'aïkido
la faillite et éviter mais à quel prix
la décision laisse un goût amer au
président du parlement chypriote
je suis cette décision est douloureuse
pour les chypriotes et plus libre cette
décision on défile une défaite de la
solidarité et de la cohésion sociale
une jeune fan de longue date clé sont
des libertés fondamentales et des
principes fondamentaux de l'union
européenne ue les réactions populaires
explose sur les écrans européens
inquiétudes et pessimisme demande enfin
je suis très inquiète en effet pour
quelles raisons pour notre vie a chip
pour nos enfants pour le futur c'est une
période très difficile à traverser
alors voilà pour ce traitement de la
sphère chypriote sur les télévisions
européennes toutes les télévisions
européennes qui ont fait leur une là
dessus et qui continuent d'ailleurs nous
sommes avec christian spillmann bonjour
bonjour vous êtes correspondant de
l'agencé france presse agence france
presse afp ici à bruxelles vous couvrez
les affaires européennes depuis 20 ans
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire est ce qu'on
peut dire que l'europe a fait une erreur
monumentale avec chypre une erreur de
communication ça c'est certain
je crois que c'est des gens qui ne
savent absolument pas communiqué
absolument pas expliquer ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire je crois qu'ils ont
fait une erreur de jeunesse avec sans
doute un peu de fébrilité de la part du
président de l'eurogroupe qui s'est
retrouvé à succéder à jack à jean claude
juncker le luxembourgeois halte à un
vieux crocodile roues et à toutes ces
négociations
là on nous a mis un jeune néerlandais
qui est tout à fait compétent moi ça
fait extraordinaire de voir qu'avec sa
candeur il nous a annoncé que dans la
grande interview qui a semé la
perturbation sur toutes les places
financières hier il a reconnu qu'il
n'avait pas compris le mouv terme
plaident ce qui voulait dire modèle il
dit moi je ne connaissais pas assez vrai
que c'est un c'est pas vraiment qu'on
utilise dans le jargon
il a donné une interview au financial
times en jugeant que ce qui avait été
fait pour chypre pouvait éventuellement
servir de modèle pour les résolution des
crises dans d'autres pays c'est bien ça
absolument il a laissé comprendre que
c'est et ça c'est en fait ce qu'il
voulait expliquer aux contribuables et
aux citoyens de l'union européenne c'est
que la règle s'est dit qu'on allait plus
payer quand tu nous manques faisait
faillite et ça tout le monde peut le
comprendre moi je suis contribuable je
suis ravi de savoir que si jamais tel ou
tel manque de telle ou telle heure en
droit de l'espace européen fait faillite
je vais pas être appelée à contribution
donc on explique effectivement les gens
qui sont dans les banques qui font de
l'argent en plaçant leur argent dans les
banques vont payer ça c'est ça qui vous
les lirez ces sacs à commission est en
train de faire sauf que effectivement
son message absolument pas passer parce
que ils n'ont pas expliqué est ce que
vous comprenez la la je dirais sur le
plan un peu plus journalistique puisque
vous êtes journaliste il ya certains ont
laissé penser qu'il pouvait y avoir un
risque de contagion des ce qu'on appelle
un bank run donc c'est à dire une
panique bancaire dans d'autres pays que
que chypre est ce que vous comprenez ça
moi ce que je comprends c'est qu'avec
les déclarations qui ont été faites hier
dans toute la zone sud de l'union
européenne que ce soit l'espagne
l'italie le portugal on se demande
maintenant si on peut laisser son argent
dans les banques et donc je pense que
les dirigeants seraient fort avisée
d'expliquer aux gens que non que vous
pouvez laisser vos dépôts que vous
économies sont protégées qu'elles vont
pas servir à combler tel ou tel trou
c'est ça le vrai message qui doivent
passer et ensuite expliqué ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire avec des banques
que l'on essaie
lisez c'est ce qu'a tenté de faire je
crois un peu françois hollande lorsqu'il
recevait cette semaine
mariano rajoy à l'elysée il a dit les
dépôts de garantie était quelque chose
ok donc on ne pouvait pas toucher selon
vous c'est pas suffisant il faut aller
plus loin dhr dans le fait de rassurer
les déposants européen je sais que les
gens n'y croient plus vous leur annoncer
que effectivement tous les dépôts
jusqu'à 100 millions sont garantis et
puis tout d'un coup vous découvrez qui
ont fait une négociation avec 17 mai de
17 ministres des finances que vous avez
un des participants
en l'occurrence les dirigeants
chypriotes qui ont accepté de taxer ces
dépôts là et que tout d'un coup on a
accepté ça alors quand j'aurais dû dire
non pas possible donc aujourd'hui les
gens ont peur nous n'y crois pas moi
personnellement je pense que beaucoup de
citoyens de l'union européenne n'ont
plus confiance aujourd'hui et c'est
dramatique
j'ai envie de vous poser la même
question que je posais tout à l'heure à
jean paul gauzès
est-ce qu'on va reparler de chypre dans
les mois qui viennent je suis pas
certain qu'on va reparler de chypre ou
même s'il ya beaucoup de problèmes
puisque je crois que voilà un état de
l'union européenne qui avait un modèle
économique et qui la fleur qui l'aurait
après mon qu'il va falloir les aider à
faire quelque chose d'autre
donc on ne sait pas très bien comment
l'économie de chypre va pouvoir se
retourner comme on les chypriotes vont
pouvoir vivre à nouveau normalement
non je pense que je crains c'est que
malheureusement dans l'union européenne
on et d'autres problèmes qui se posent
d'ailleurs qui vont réclamer que ça soit
en italie que ça soit en slovénie et et
même dans des pays qui frappent à la
porte de la zone euro et on se demande
si vraiment ces pays sont aptes à
rentrer à intégrer cet espace de 17 pays
qui ont la monnaie l'euro comme monnaie
commune et les communes christian
spillmann merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
à nos questions va reste évidemment en
europe
on part en irlande il ya quelques mois
une femme a été morte parce qu'elle
n'avait pas pu apporter
nous avons voulu savoir quelle était la
situation de l'avortement là bas dans ce
pays nous allons retrouver ensuite
kathia gilder et son avis thème est tout
de suite
le direction l'irlande avec ce reportage
signé flora sauvage
fait divers tragique une femme enceinte
de 31 ans meurt après avoir demandé un
avortement qui lui a été refusée automne
2012 après le décès de sa vita à la pana
var le débat sur l'avortement est
relancé en irlande ce fait divers
dramatique suscite un tollé général dans
le pays où lee vg reste interdite
après 5 référendum ce n'est pas la
première fois que la question revient
sur le devant de la scène
niall birane dirige le planning familial
ici on milite en faveur de la levée de
l'interdiction de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
en 1983 un amendement dans la
constitution introduit l'idée que la vie
de la mère et celle de son bébé ont la
même valeur
depuis il n'y a pas une loi pour
préciser ce que cela signifie réellement
il a fallu un drame en 1992 pour
remettre en question cet amendement une
adolescente de 14 ans tombée enceinte
après un viol à qui on avait refusé un
avortement a conduit la cour suprême à
se prononcer on a eu une interprétation
de la cour suprême en 1992 qui dit que
si la vie de la mère est en danger
un avortement est envisageable mais la
difficulté c'est qu'aucune législation
n'a été mis en place aucune consigne n'a
été donnée au corps médical
si bien qu'aujourd'hui encore recourir à
une ivg est passible de la réclusion à
perpétuité
chaque année 5000 irlandaises vont à
l'étranger pour se faire avorter
en trente ans près de 150000 fall ont
fait le voyage
car ni reland le poids de l'église a
toujours empêché les évolutions en la
matière les catholiques restent
farouchement opposés à l'avortement
cole kids light and on à dieu donne la
vie et personne n'a le pouvoir d' ôter
la vie à part du sud j'aspire donc je ne
pense pas qu'on ait la liberté d'avorter
non sublet un enfant je suis fatigué
d'entendre ce qui se sont accros name
libéraux ils ont ce perdu la foi dans de
très très très très très rares cas
d'accord mais en dehors de ça non ça va
à l'encontre de la loi de dieu de la loi
de la nature
en 2010 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné l'irlande à cause du
flou juridique qui entoure l'avortement
sous la pression internationale le
gouvernement s'est engagé à déposer un
projet de loi avant l'été une décision
saluée par sept députés de gauche
elle milite en faveur de la
libéralisation de l'avortement
le gouvernement a traîné des pieds
depuis des années sur cette question
c'est tout à fait historique même si ça
ne concerne qu'un petit nombre de femmes
symboliquement c'est très important car
ça veut dire que pour la première fois
en irlande
nous allons avoir une loi sur
l'avortement et c'est pour cette raison
que les opposants sont si énervé qu'il
manifeste tant est qu'il met autant
d'argent pour des campagnes de publicité
financée par les états unis
car en irlande les lobbys pro vie sont
très influents pour les opposants à
l'avortement le foetus est un être
humain dès les premiers instants de la
vie
evelyne travail au sein de l'association
pro life campaign elle a participé aux
manifestations anti avortement de ces
derniers mois raison pour laquelle
l'avortement est une question qui pose
problème c'est qu'il y a deux vies en
jeu il y a deux corps
ce n'est pas que ma vie qui est en jeu
c'est aussi l'avis de mon bébé donc les
deux doivent être protégés
et cette vision est relayée au parlement
par le sénateur mullen l'opposition à
l'avortement en irlande est souvent
présentée comme une question
exclusivement religieuse dans une
société plurielle
on ne veut pas légiférer à partir de la
foi de certains mais c'est une mauvaise
compréhension de nos positions
la façon dont je vois les choses que oui
bien sûr on est inspiré par la foi mais
cela relève du bon sens
un instinct naturel de protection des
droits de l'homme mais les mentalités
évoluent la jeunesse est plus ouverte
sur la question même si l'avortement
sans motif apparent n'est pas encore à
l'ordre du jour peut-être que les vieux
se rend compte mais pas la génération de
nos parents
je pense que ça devrait être légalisé
car c'est le corps de la femme la
décision doit lui appartenir
et de toute façon dans quelques années
je pense que ça sera légal alors
pourquoi pas maintenant je ne suis pas
d'accord avec elle car il s'agit d'une
vie à l'intérieur de soi
je dis ça maintenant mais si jamais je
tombais en somme dans six mois je serai
peut-être la première allait apporter
alors je ne sais pas malgré le déclin de
l'influencé de l'église catholique en
irlande les esprits évoluent lentement
d'après un sondage 85% des irlandais
sont favorables à l'avortement si la vie
de la mère est en danger
seuls 36% des personnes interrogées se
prononcent pour la légalisation de lives
et g quelles que soient les raisons
une enquête tourné à dublin en irlande
par flora sauvage nous sommes revenus à
bruxelles avec nous sur ce plateau
marc tarabella bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes député européen
d'origine belge et grand défenseur des
droits de la femme et de la cause
féminine
une première question peut-être sur ce
reportage est ce que ça vous choque
qu'un tel drame ce décès de savita à la
navarre morte sans possibilité d'avorter
est ce que ça vous choque qu'un tel
drame survienne dans un pays qui est
actuellement président de l'union
européenne oui c'est choquant parce que
c'est la résultante qu'on le veuille ou
non d'un obscurantisme religieux qui
sévit encore en irlande et cette pauvre
savita devaient fermer à la fin une
fausse couche et on a refusé de
l'avorter alors que l'enfant était plus
les têtes plus envie ou n'allait être
plus envie et elle a souffert de
septicémie et elle en est décédé est
donc clairement au moins pour les
raisons médicales évidente
cet avortement devait être opéré il ne
l'a pas été et ça a coûté une vie d'une
jeune femme est clairement et qui avait
envie de donner donner la vie c'est tout
salon des raisons médicales mais
clairement la situation évolue dans le
bon sens mais elle évolue lentement en
irlande qui reste un des deux pays de
l'union européenne où l'avortement est
illégal
alors effectivement ce droit à
l'avortement n'est pas reconnue partout
en europe et ce que vous observez vous
un retour en arrière dans certains pays
qui autorisent aujourd'hui l'avortement
par exemple en espagne ce que vous
observez certaines pratiques plus ou
moins insidieuse qui tendrait à remettre
ce droit il faut se méfier des retours
en arrière car effectivement dans
plusieurs pays a des velléités de
changer les lois est d'ailleurs la
principale l'espagne notamment mais le
mouvement pro life sont actifs dans
toute une série de pays et voudrait
qu'on revienne en arrière sur les lois
qui ont autorisé lives et g et donc on
n'est pas garanti je dirais une fois que
la loi est votée
d'une part qui est pas de retour en
arrière car certains ne veulent et
deuxièmement sur le terrain il faut se
méfier aussi dans la pratique de
l'accessibilité de la réduction
d'accessibilité de la femme à pouvoir
faire une interruption volontaire de
grossesse quand elles le souhaitent
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des hôpitaux qui
ferment parce qu'il ya une pression
sociale certains hôpitaux ne veulent pas
le faire
certains médecins qui objecte finalement
le cas de conscience refuse de le faire
et il ya des difficultés y compris en
belgique
à cet égard là il ya des différences de
situation selon les pays puisque donc
l'avortement n'est pas un droit partout
en europe est ce que vous pensez qu'il
existe une frontière entre une ligne de
fracture mais entre deux europes lui
vraiment un peu permissive est plutôt
libérale sur ce type de questions et
l'autre est conservatrice et
moralisatrice est ce que vous sentez une
fracture nette jeu sonic ou non parce
que 25 pays sur 27 l'ont légalisé donc
c'est quand même une large majorité qui
restent qui pays qui doivent le faire
est clairement je sens aussi une
évolution même au sein du parlement
européen il ya trois ans j'ai fait
réinscrire dans un texte le droit à la
femme à disposer de son corps et à
pouvoir avoir un accès aisé à la
contraception à l'avortement il ya huit
ans que ce n'était pas acceptée
maintenant ça l'est parce que le
parlement européen s'est féminisé 35%
détenus sont des femmes et il est
rajeunie et que les jeunes générations
un petit peu comme dans le reportage les
jeunes générations de députés comme les
jeunes générations de citoyens sont
beaucoup plus ouverts sur la question
est y compris dans des groupes dans le
groupe chrétien démocrate qui est
souvent plus réticents à cela souffler
les français qui ont la loi la loi mais
il a quand même
ils y sont évidemment eu favorable avec
quelques autres mais même dans des pays
de l'europe centrale de l'europe de
l'est et même sûrement à malte par
exemple qui interdit formellement
l'avortement
vous êtes entendu aussi par vos
collègues de malte très difficilement
mais les collègues maltais de mon groupe
ont voté cette ce texte donc clairement
il ya une évolution j'irai dans le bon
sens y compris au niveau des élus au
delà de toutes considérations
religieuses ou morales est ce que vous
trouvez que le niveau d'information et
de connaissance sur l'avortement est
suffisant en europe pour permettre aux
femmes confrontées à un choix quand
elles le peuvent de choisir en
conséquence de cause
souvent c'est que les femmes sont sont
assez informés
non il n'ya pas d'éducation affective et
sexuelle correctement donné dans le
cursus scolaire à l'adolescence dont
généralement selon les pays d'europe y
en a où ça se fait en haoussa se fait
pas deuxième chose le centre de planning
familial sont très utiles pour
conseiller ils doivent être accessibles
ils ne sont pas répandus et là aussi
elle est différent selon les pays
donc évidemment on peut toujours faire
mieux en terme d'information je le pense
alors une autre question qui concerne
sur cette question du droit des femmes à
disposer d'elle-même
c'est celui de droit de prendre une
contraception est actuellement on parle
beaucoup des pilules contraceptives
notamment de 3e et 4e génération dont
certaines auraient provoqué des décès
c'est en tout cas les chiffres de l'
agence nationale française du médicament
qui dans son rapport estime que la
pilule contraceptive a provoqué 20 décès
sur les dernières années est ce que pour
vous ces pilules la présente des dangers
pour la santé quel niveau d'information
vous en tant que député européen vous
avez moi j'ai souhaité quand le débat
sur la pilule de 3e et 4e génération a
surgi c'est qu'il ya une information
claire de la part des fabricants de de
ce type de contraceptif c'est qu'il
c'est qu'ils disent clairement de quelle
génération et la pilule puisque le
risque notamment d'avoir je pense que
c'est des avc et doubler selon la
génération des pilules si lille reste
infime tout de même et puis peut-être
faut-il aussi au niveau des
prescripteurs de contraceptifs peut-être
avoir recourt aussi à d'autres moyens je
pense notamment au stérilet qui peut
être efficace dans certains cas et quand
il ya un risque avéré peut-être ou en
tout cas plus importants chez certaines
femmes c'est peut-être dû se diriger
vers un autre moyen de contraception
on a parfois l'impression que les
prescripteurs vont très volontiers vers
ce qui peut apparaître comme le seul
moyen moderne de contraception est ce
que les laboratoires pharmaceutiques ont
aussi une responsabilité dans cette
affaire
oui comme d'information a donné assez
d'informations là aussi c'est un nom
trop d'info tué l'info on est bien au
courant mais à partir du moment où
l'information a été donnée que les
pilules de dernière génération troisième
et quatrième avec comporter un risque
plus élevé autant mettre sur la boîte
que de quelle génération et la pilule
qui est prescrite
merci beaucoup marc tarabella devant
était avec nous sur ce plateau c'est la
fin de cette émission se retrouve dans
deux semaines à bruxelles avec françois
vos données très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires